a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj sbagliato schermata di
gioco perfetto io sono felice io oggi
siamo su angry il red button
sarebbe un giochino tipo troll face
quest bisogna tentare di schiacciare il
pulsante rosso
la partenza c'è scritto play e sono già
incassato che non ci sia un pulsante da
cliccare ma va bene ci sarà un pulsante
rosso lo schiacciare eccolo non me l'ho
mai detto ma ho un debole per i pulsanti
cioè se io vedo un pulsante rosso in
giro lo schiaccio tante volte era
scattato l'allarme a scuola a caso aver
agazzi partiamo prima che diventi
tragica la cosa da start capitolo 1
ragazzi un nuovo inizio più di monica
parlano pure i pulsanti parlano
fantastico che mani è la sap certo senti
pare il friday eight spray dell ultimo
giorno di lavoro ragazzi che sa qualcosa
mi dice che mette i puntini
non me l'aspettavo mi ricorda un po il
mio carattere quando ero a scuola
proprio dello stesso tipo di parola e
rosso stai bene tutti quanti mi
schiacciano sempre dai amico sono sicuro
che non è così male lo pensi davvero
guarda guarda che cosa succede sempre
succede sempre ancora e ancora e ancora
mi sento uno stronzo e ancora e ancora e
ancora e ancora e lo sai una cosa
potresti semplicemente scappare si hai
ragione nessuno ti guarderebbe davvero
amico ti copriamo alle spalle ma il
rosso te lo meriti già state cosa giusta
due ragazzi siete sicuri che non diremo
non diremo assolutamente niente
ok lo sto facendo si sta staccando ma
per che cosa fa 6 a brown marco sogni
infranti capitolo 2
chi è sei tu non vedi che sto dormendo
sei cieco per favore lasciami solo tono
serio non farmi dare di matto sei
stupido dipende sarei qua per tutto il
giorno
premendo bottoni come un idiota perché
questo quello che sei un idiota uno
stupido umano ritardato senza una vita
senza un cervello e con delle dita
noiose non lo diresti se fossi una
ragazza sai dove ti puoi infilare col
cazzo di vito sì proprio la adesso
lasciami sono no mi spiace zio a me ne
vado e senti io ti odio
bravo fi later [ __ ] con l'alcol ecco
l'ho preso
ma c'è un qualcosa di più difficile per
un primate come te hai sentito un
primate guzzi io sono immortale tu non
lo sai tu sei una merda perché se l'ho
insultato da un pulsante del cazzo ti
odio ti odio odio la mia vita
odio tutto il sostentendo una merda
[ __ ]
non voglio parlarti più kay sainte i
fratelli possiamo aggiungere un accordo
e se vuoi me ne vado
no no non puoi andare dove cazzo va e
spari ragazzi inseguiamo dobbiamo
inseguiamo capitolo 3 prendimi così
pensi di saper volare
mi dispiace per te ma i primati non
volano e la madonna
eccolo su cup preso preso ok calmati
calmo zio calmo calmo ok
cos'è si mai il mio capezzolo e sempre
più belle sì si depila quest'uomo noè
non si depila ascoltati tutti leveresti
dal cazzo che mi fai schifo ati trascino
io sul pene di trascino perfetto a posto
ecco devo toccare lo schiacciarli il
pube è una roba che io nella mia vita
speravo di non far mai staccare ecco
perfetto è posto anche qui non ha
intenzione di fermarsi no frate adesso
va via è impossibile trovarmi merda mi
spiace frate se sei stupido
gli usa che mi sembra di essere tornato
bambino quando giocava la chiappa la
talpa mai zio preso preso già fatta
pregare dispiace un po mi sta sul cuore
sto ragazzo capitolo 4 il patatine al
cioccolato certo casi o da posto
posso schiacciarti pube o perché non
vuoi semplicemente a giocare fuori
perché è mezzanotte frate sono sicuro
che tu sia un ciccione si sia vero il
problema è che mangio anche 25 hamburger
e non ingrasso un cazzo quanto pesi ma
che cosa te ne frega 305 no no forse
quattro di me pensano così tanto non ti
credo e non ci crede che cazzo sei un
ciccione vabbè [ __ ] ma perché non
ha gli occhi zio però che la scatola di
biscotti protesi è il ciccione ciccione
non so non ciccione [ __ ] lo vuoi un
biscotto biscotto biscotto ciccione
ciccione
non so far oer il no niente biscotto per
il ciccione non sembri stare tanto bene
amico mio si è questo ragazzo laggiù non
vuole lasciarmi in pace
il ragazzo ciccio nella gente non sarà
un ciccione puoi smetterla di premere
mio amico prendi qualcuno della tua
taglia patch nessuno ti darà più
fastidio rosso affinché lo scasso tardi
dai di te che casino oddio che bordello
nassi serio
mi dispiace frate schiaccia mi ancora e
vedrai che cosa succede va bene zio le
conseguenze dei suoi atti
oh merda devo schiacciarlo mentre c'è la
lama che gira a madonna e bea minchia
impossibile se lo sto facendo
bye bye bye e vabbè ricerca è diventata
una sfida all'ultimo sangue vai così
manco blog burning così difficile lo so
che è fattibile
no vabbè che la cosa più impossibile
cambiamento sì sì sì ce l'ho fatta
madonna peggio di street fighter dai che
è morto lei che muore mondo ragazzi ci
siamo c'è una fine perfetto grazie
grazie di progaming il bottone rosso è
morto è morto
mi spiace zio l'ho ucciso proprio è
morto ma no ma poverino
ho segnato mica che mira a sei serio
fermo piano dentro bravo zio dentro
perfetto non massacrato praticamente
ragazzi lo pratica ma mi sono fatto
autogol lucida farmi autogol perfetto
che ha visto giocando da solo ma chi
sono io dei due ma sono quella destra e
penso di essere con la sinistra perfetto
rosa roba infilarlo nel tostapane
perfetto ok non è una mia scelta raga è
proprio e masochismo questi spiato per
essere sa di cine la fine non può finire
oddio no l'ho ucciso
ho commesso un tasti cidio dibatto ma
come una cosa devo acquistare il bottone
sui gay madeinchina cuore va bene
acquistiamo e finito così i ragazzi è
finito veramente così ragazzi abbiamo
fatto il possibile credetemi per
salvarlo io ci ho provato tutto quello
che volevo dirgli è che tutte le cose
rosse possono essere toccate
va bè ragazzi concludo che l'episodio
spero che vi sia piaciuto se vi è
piaciuto schiacciate il pulsante rosso
qui sotto che il tasto iscriviti e che
anche il tasto di mi piace il tasto mi
piace
no quelle blu vabbè schiacciato la di
sette daltonici ragazzi ghiacciate il
pulsante blu e quindi ragazzi servito è
piaciuto se lasciato quanto mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come io
non sto attento tiziana sensi di
crederci mi chiamo prossimo vinto
allargasse e rosso questo è rosso
cammino